dignity health was founded in 1986 and
they're known for their facility fitness
instructors specialty counselors
and registered dietitians in order to
help people stay strong
healthy and fit well once the pandemic
hit they had to renovate themselves or
reinvent themselves and also find some
new ways to which they could
promote wellness while still staying
safe eight news now reporter sally
jaramillo tells us how they were able to
find a new platform
and also continue to make a difference
in the valley
it was pretty remarkable because we had
to shut our doors on march 17th
abby gaida is a health educator for
dignity health
she vividly remembers the day when
everything had to close
we are so used to having hundreds of
people walk in and out of our door
for engagement for classes to have a
great time and stay healthy
and we're like we can't turn that off we
still need to you know serve our
community and provide these
resources for them for me was a day
where uh
was really uncertain you know i'm always
planning ahead on my classes
tawanda evans mcintosh is an educator
for infants and toddlers at dignity
health
parents and grandparents would rely on
her weekly classes
she immediately jumped on facebook live
and within seconds
over a hundred people joined we wanted
to create something that was solid
and consistent it was very foreign to us
i mean no one really did know about zoom
at that time what started off with 20
classes
immediately started to expand as of now
we
are reaching over more than 21 000
individuals in the community
and over 1600 classes all of which
continue to be free
and you just need the internet we do
start off with a lot of the classes that
are very vital and important
so staying healthy with our chronic
disease programs
one-on-one with the registered dietitian
and fitness
but now we have everywhere from infant
classes mommy and baby classes
support groups and to really help people
manage their health at home during these
times
i still remember my first doom with my
kids because i couldn't see them
with facebook you can't see anything
with the zoom i was able to see them
mcintosh says seeing and hearing the
children gave her encouragement
that we will get through this the
face-to-face
interaction that we're really used to
seeing in our classrooms um you know
nothing's going to really
beat that but we we know that this is
going to be going on
and we're like you know what we're very
happy that we're still able to deliver
this
in a very quick way when we see a need
we're right there and ready to fill it
saliva 8 news now so not only are they
reaching people in nevada but a lot of
their participants are reaching out to
their family members that live in other
states
their average size class is now in their
30s
state